le fjord du saguenay et ses caps
majestueux sont une grande source
d'inspiration pour le militaire et
musicien martin lapierre
les premières images que j'ai eue
c'était en gros mon enfance quand on
faisait des voyages avec l'école
c'est un arbre qui est unique au monde
ça s'inscrit dans mon inconscience
france des années plus tard mais sa
sortie en 2011 lors d'une mission en
afghanistan avec le royal 22e régiment
le technicien médical frôlé la mort au
cours d'une patrouille ils marchent sur
une mine
mais par miracle la charge n'explose pas
cet événement devient l'élément
déclencheur pour la réalisation d'un
rêve c'était comme si je réalisais
vraiment content qu'on pouvait mourir
j'ai pas été le seul c'est une histoire
unique le trac sommet je te fait partie
du métier on l'acceptent sur mes taxes
sur le vix pop survivre à malabo la
seconde après puis les jours après tu
commences à penser bien noté vraiment
pour ses proches sur ce à partir de ce
moment alors vraiment quel âge est
décédée de da produire la musique t il
amorce donc l'écriture d'une pièce
intitulée quatre unités
c'est la métaphore dans le fond le cap
c'est toutes les raisons pour partir
puis combattent l'extrémisme relève le
hockey c'est les toutes les raisons pour
venir aussi
martin lapierre a découvert la musique
dès son plus jeune âge
montgobert nokia nous un peu de ce type
là on reste un nom de ponte amis très
riches sont restés dans un cat ennemi
puis lui reste un an au pis j'avais
pensé mise avant midi lui donc c'est
complètement pour diriger votre
pédagogie du tout j'avais progressé mais
rien d'autre
le militaire de 38 ans a aussi appris à
composer de façon autodidacte il lui
aura fallu quatre ans pour compléter
l'écriture de son premier album est
départ l'orchestrateur teddy les hanches
et il ne ménage aucun effort
le premier extrait la pièce cap trinité
a été enregistré avec un orchestre
symphonique à budapest
c'était vraiment un grand moment
d'émotion
deux rappels des premières fois que
j'entends des sceaux dans ma tête je
marchais dans le sable avec un fusil
puis après ça d'état si pendant quarante
musiciens qui jouent son devoir s'est
concrétisée loge au site est assez
incroyable pour des motifs financiers
seule la première pièce a été enregistré
un projet d'album important qu'ils
financent entièrement et qu'il espère
compléter au cours des prochaines années
c'est un symbole vraiment je pense je
pense que chaque chaque soldat au canada
qui est parti de son propre cas je pense
ici julie larouche radio-canada rivière
éternité